pour les cueillir on les ramasse par le
pédoncule par la queue dans ses attaques
pour éviter de marquer le fruit de ses
rétros le fruit et puis après il suffit
de croquer dedans avec une quinzaine de
jours de retard à cause de la météo des
mois d'avril et de mai la saison des
fraises est enfin arrivé
le principe de laquelle de gally est
très simple c'est un espace qui est en
accès libre c'est à dire que les gens
arrivent ils se garent sur notre parking
il ya un grand panneau qui présente
toutes les productions du moment qui
sont à maturité avec le prix de chaque
production puis après les gens viennent
soit ils prennent une brouette qu'on met
à leur disposition à l'entrée de
l'entrée du lieu où ils viennent avec
leurs cabas une dizaine de variétés de
fraises sont cultivés à galilée
fraisiers sont plantés soit en hauteur
sur des gouttières soit directement au
sol le but limiter les traitements en
limitant le contact aux mauvaises herbes
vous voyez ces phrases là sont cultivés
sur des sur des gouttières on a mis à la
fin de l'hiver début du printemps
c'est pain de substrats dans lequel on a
planté un tous nos pieds de fraises la
clientèle ainsi que les fraises sont au
rendez vous le plein non j'en profite
enfin point profite ma femme imprévu de
courtes eu un dépôt le but c'est que
chacun une barque est pleine et ramène
chez soi donc je pense qu'on finira
peut-être 6,7 kg
la cueillette va pouvoir durer tout
l'été les fraises de saison jusqu'en
juillet et les remontantes pourront être
cueillies jusqu'en octobre